najat vallaud-belkacem ministre des
droits de la femme et porte parole du
gouvernement est l'invité de preuves par
3 bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous pour
cette émission réalisée en partenariat
avec l' agence france presse qui sera
représentée sur ce plateau tout à
l'heure par isabelle tournée et
dailymotion et piperi tarnos bien sûr
nous rejoindre à nous durant la
troisième partie de cette émission comme
chaque semaine le débat s'enflamme najat
vallaud-belkacem après le retour des
ultras du psg au coeur de paris violence
destruction place du trocadéro le
ministre de l'intérieur le ministère de
l'intérieur d'ailleurs au sens large est
mis en accusation
il est difficile de nier qu'il ya eu un
manque d'anticipation c'est assurer le
maintien de l'ordre c'est un métier moi
je veux bien que chacun y aille de son
petit commentaire mais la première des
choses c'est que la première des
responsabilités c'est celle des ultras
en question c'est celle de ceux qui ont
choisi de vandaliser toute la place du
trocadéro de blesser des gens puisque je
vous rappelle quelqu'un est mis plus
d'une trentaine de blessés
et à cet égard donc il ya eu des
interpellations une quarantaine je crois
qui se continue encore aujourd'hui grâce
au dispositif
j'ai l'impression de voleurs voilà est
donc la première des responsabilités
c'est celle-là sali son match il est
coupable messieurs il ya les gendarmes
aussi ça lui sert maintenant grand train
de l'ordre c'est un sujet que je suis
allé à regarder de près m'étonnant en
effet de la façon dont les choses
s'enflammer dans les commentaires il se
trouve que sur la place du trocadéro où
étaient réunies 15000 personnes 800
agents de police ont été mobilisés ceux
qui connaissent un petit peu ce type de
dispositif simple que 800 officiers
mobilisés pour 15000 personnes
c'est un bon ratio donc je crois que la
préfecture de police a fait son travail
maintenant on ne peut que déplorer qu'il
y ait des casseurs en effet qu'il soit
venu gâcher la fête et du faux que les
interpellations soit suivi d'effets
devant la justice il n'y a pas que la
droite qui déclenche les hostilités
contre le ministre de l'intérieur
françois rebsamen le patron des
sénateurs ps est assez cash il le disait
sur public sénat aujourd'hui il n'écarte
pas une responsabilité du ministère de
l'intérieur
on exclut est totalement je n'ai pas
entendu ces propos de françois rebsamen
gestion très bien moi j'estime que la
police a fait son travail et j'estime
surtout j'irai plus loin
qu'il s'agisse de ces débordements là où
d'autres débordements comme ceux
auxquels on a assisté dans le cadre des
manifestations anti mariage pour tous il
faut en permanence à veut avoir un
discours politique très claire et
condamné les débordements eux mêmes et
non pas aller chercher des
responsabilités dans la façon dont les
débordements ont été limités restreint
gérer le vrai sujet c'est pourquoi ces
débordements ont eu lieu et c'est
comment on peut travailler à ce qu'il
n'ait plus lieu et c'est pour ça que
manuel valls le ministre de l'intérieur
on reçoit cet après midi même notamment
le paris saint-germain la ligue de
football la ville de paris pour préparer
à l'avenir une gestion de ce type de
risque qu'ils soient la plus optimale
possible car il a déjà été lancé par le
préfet qu'il n'y aura plus de
manifestations festives pour le psg dans
les rues de la capitale est ce que le
gouvernement le ministère de l'intérieur
en cd à tort aux riches
pg qatari qui voulait absolument pour sa
fête
la tour eiffel en arrière-plan mais vous
savez la gestion des risques
c'est à la fois anticiper prévoir les
choses et puis s'adapter quand en effet
des débordements ont eu lieu
donc en termes d'anticipation il était
difficile d'imaginer que plusieurs
centaines de casseurs allait se laisser
aller au vandalisme auquel on a fait
partie de l'histoire du club et donc il
faut lutter contre le hooliganisme je
suis bien d'accord avec vous et c'est
une action qui est en cours et à partir
du moment où on a assisté aux événements
qu'on a vu hier soir et bien des mesures
fortes ont été décidées notamment sur
l'interdiction de la descente sur la
scène qui avaient été autorisées
initialement et vous voyez bien que la
réactivité donc hélas bon alors il donc
pas question de faire tomber des têtes
si on poursuit puisque la responsabilité
de ne pas s'engager dès côtés du
ministre de l'intérieur par exemple jean
françois copé demande au moins le départ
du préfet bernard beaucourt accusés
d'amateurisme
mais jean françois copé ne se grandit
pas une fois de plus par ses propos je
vous rappelle que des incidents aux
abords du parc des princes où d'autres
manifestations sportives on en a
souvent y compris en plein coeur de
paris lorsque nous étions dans
l'opposition vous souvenez vous nous
avoir entendus alors réclamer des têtes
ça n'est pas comme ça qu'on gère
sérieusement en responsabilité les
questions de sécurité
est ce que le gouvernement serait
favorable à une commission d'enquêté
parlementaire qui est réclamé par la
droite sur les événements du trocadéro
aurait également été champs elysées
c'est le gouvernement à chaque fois
qu'il a été saisi d'une demande de
commission d'enquêté parlementaire a
répondu par la positive pour le moment
il appartient au ministre de l'intérieur
évidemment de se prononcer mais à priori
le gouvernement laisse le parlement
faire son travail
savez vous avez évoqué les
manifestations contre le mariage pour
tous ont dit justement que les forces de
l'ordre sont épuisés depuis des mois de
manifestations qui ont profité de ces
incidents
l'oeuvre de casseurs pour demander aux
opposants des mariages pour tous
maintenant qu'il a été voté de se calmer
un peu et de relâcher un peu la pression
sur les policiers et crs
si vous permettez ça n'est pas au motif
que les policiers les crs seraient
épuisés qu'on demande aux manifestants
et aux casseurs d'arrêter leurs
débordements
c'est au nom du principe de des règles
républicaines et de la démocratie et je
vous rappelle qu'en démocratie
nous avons voté au parlement ce texte
portant sur le mariage pour tous qu en
démocratie il appartient aujourd'hui au
conseil constitutionnel de se prononcer
sur la constitutionnalité de ce texte
est donc que de fait les manifestations
et a fortiori les débordements non plus
place dans le débat public
alors on reviendra sur cette question du
mariage pour tous dans un instant et
qu'ils avaient le tour n'est peut-être
votre appréhension avant la décision du
conseil constitutionnel cette semaine le
remaniement on a bien compris
place beauvau n'est pas à l'ordre du
jour pour vous najat vallaud-belkacem
mais il est dit on dans toutes les têtes
des ministres il faut un chef à bercy
c'est numéro deux du gouvernement qui le
dit laurent fabius qui semblent exposés
là ce qui se dessine écoutez il m'est
difficile de commenter les commentaires
des autres
je ne sais pas ce que laurent fabius a
dit exactement
quelle question un chef à bercy et passe
sept ministres comme c'est le cas
aujourd'hui
je crois qu'il ne nous appartient pas de
nous prononcer sur les portefeuilles des
uns et des autres je crois que cela
relève du seul président de la
république et du seul premier ministre
et que c'est à eux de savoir s'ils le
souhaitent ils décident de procéder à
des modifications de portefeuilles
aujourd'hui vous avez trente sept
ministres qui sont au travail qui sont
dans des chantiers qui sont très
nombreux très prenant et j'aimerais
aussi qu'on me regarde l'activité
gouvernementale plutôt que de passer
beaucoup de temps à commenter des
suppositions des supputations d'euros
mais c'est en rapport direct avec
l'action du gouvernement vous avez 10 37
ministres mais sept ministres dans la
seule citadelle de bercy dans cette
vaste galaxie comme des gamins ségolène
royal c'est trop mais vous voulez que je
vous donne mon sentiment sur ce sujet je
ne sais pas de quoi on parle
le fait que sept ministres soient
installés à bercy physiquement
géographiquement ne signifie pas qu'ils
gèrent les mêmes dossiers marché depuis
des années ce faire vous avez vous été
surpris je vous en donne des exemples
vous avez un ministre de l'économie et
des finance vous avez un ministre du
budget vous avez un ministre du
redressement productif une ministre de
l'artisanat du commerce et du tourisme
sur les gens chacun d'eux d'autres sont
pas sur la même ligne
vous avez cité pierre moscovici qui
l'emportent c'est celle de jean marc
ayrault qui est chef du gouvernement
voilà et la solidarité gouvernementale
commandes que lorsque le premier
ministre à arbitrer entre plusieurs
possibilités et bien ce soit la ligne
qu'ils soient respectés jean marc
ayrault justement est-ce qu'il est
indispensable à françois hollande comme
l'affirment son épouse brigitte je crois
en tout cas que jean marc ayrault est un
bon premier ministre
d'abord profondément convaincu des
réformes qu'il engage qu'il a déjà
engagé nombreuses ensuite profondément
loyal fidèle
et que de ce point de vue là en effet
ils font avec françois hollande
un très bon tandem louis jusqu'au
service des français on n'imaginait pas
son départ de matignon avant l'an
prochain des élections municipales et
européennes
mais je vais vous dire moi je pense que
nous avons besoin de jean marc ayrault
s'est il faut enfin vraiment faut avoir
conscience de la somme de courage et
d'audace qu'ont réclamé les réformes que
nous avons entreprise pendant sept
dernières années
il vous en faudra qu'ils ont annoncé
qu'ils viennent mais justement mettre
sur la table comme nous l'avons fait un
pacte pour la compétitivité avec
notamment 20 milliards d'allègements de
charges pour les entreprises des
contrats de génération dont on espère
500 mille embauches sur cinq ans un
grand plan pour le logement permettant
de créer deux millions et demi de
logements sur les cinq années à venir
c'est quand même pas des petites mesures
une réforme fiscale rétablissant de la
justice et de l'équité
donc ces mesures que nous avons déjà
engagé en tête-- audacieuse courageuses
ont même surpris je crois beaucoup
d'observateurs à certains égards
eh bien nous avons besoin que ce courage
et cette audace porté par jean marc
ayrault soit au rendez vous de ce qui
nous attend la réforme des retraites la
réforme des allocations familiales la
préparation de l'avenir avec de grands
chantiers des grands investissements
pour projeter notre pays dans le futur
je crois que j'ai fondée sur logiquement
le bilan de l'an 1
mais on n'entend ségolène royal dont
vous avez été proche peut-être lettre
vous êtes vous toujours physique du
temps a été perdu la première année
qu'il faut bien désormais aller beaucoup
plus vite alors donc le message ait été
reçu par françois hollande
c'est ce qu'a dit ségolène royal qui
doit accélérer
si vous permettez pour être proche de
ségolène royal je suis avec attention
on est fier ce que ce qu'elle peut
écrire ou dire je ne crois pas qu'elle
est affirmé que nous ayons perdu du
temps
elle dit une promotion de son dernier
livre elle a déclaré vivre dans le monde
estime que du temps a été perdu la
première année ce qu'elle a dit en effet
c'est que des choses ont été réalisées
dans un premier temps et que les
français ont un rapport au temps qui est
un rapport différent de celui des
administrations et dans lequel il est
attendu de nous que nous accélérions la
mise en oeuvre de nos réformes et que
nous projetions plus encore notamment
dans cette fameuse préparation damien
elle parle de transition écologique elle
parle de développement du numérique les
secteurs porteurs d'avenir
mais au fond c'est précisément ce que
disait françois hollande à la sortie du
séminaire du 6 mai dernier lorsque il
préparé l'an 2 l'an 2 du quinquennat à
venir qui porte sur trois priorités
l'emploi toujours l'emploi la jeunesse
et la préparation de l'avenir notamment
avec ce programme d'investissement qui
va être présenté bientôt par le premier
ministre est ce que la conférence de
presse du chef de l'état jeudi donnera
le signal d'un nouveau souffle pour
donner espère notamment en matière
d'emploi c'est ça l'enjeu notamment je
crois vraiment que l'enjeu numéro un
pour les français c'est l'emploi parce
que de l'emploi ou d'une chômage
malheureusement découle beaucoup de
choses c'est de l'emploi que découle la
capacité à se loger
la capacité à faire vivre sa famille la
capacité à se soigner
bref l'indépendance l'autonomie
financière et donc tout ce que nous
pourrons faire pour lutter contre la
progression du chômage et pour atteindre
cet objectif d'une inversion de la
courbe du chômage d'ici la fin de
l'année 2013 est le bienvenu nous avons
déjà fait beaucoup de choses en réalité
les emplois d'avenir les contrats de
génération
l'accord national interprofessionnel
signé par les partenaires sociaux sur le
mois cette semaine on va entrer en
récession
oui sauf que le chômage qui est en train
d'augmenter mois après mois
c'est le résultat de politiques
économiques qui ont été conduites
il y a des mois et les politiques
économiques que nous conduisons nous
depuis deux trois mois car après tout le
contrat de génération par exemple a été
adoptée par l'assemblée le parlement y a
moi la réforme du marché du travail elle
va être adoptée je l'espère aujourd'hui
même au sénat et bien le résultat de ces
politiques là on comprend très bien
qu'il faille trois quatre cinq mois que
on en voit les effets concrets un mot
sur la réforme des retraites mais parler
de courage et nos enfants droit parce
que vous avez combattu dans l'opposition
toutes les formes qu'elle était engagée
par la droite aujourd'hui est-ce que la
réforme de gauche c'est travailler plus
longtemps pour gagner moins
aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup de paramètres
qui sont sur la table
vous savez comment nous allons procéder
nous l'avons dit nous avons été
transférés
on connaît on connaît la procédure bien
attention certains sûr mais c'est dur
est importante puisque c'est dur méthode
de dialogue social c'est celle qui nous
a permis d'aboutir à cette réforme du
marché du travail comme on n'en avait
pas vu depuis trois mois on annonce a
poussé à 44 annuités la durée de
cotisation nécessaire s'agissant donc de
la reine celle des recettes
la procédure importe car concrètement il
a été demandé à un comité des retraites
une commission des retraites est
présidée par yannick moreau d'étudier
plusieurs scénarii possibles
elle est au travail elle rendra ses
conclusions à la mi juin
ensuite lors de la grande conférence
sociale ces scénarii seront présentées
par le gouvernement aux partenaires
sociaux avec une concertation
oui mais en fait ce que je cherche à
vous expliquer c'est que je vais pas
vous dévoiler ici c'est comme scénario
puisque l'idée c'est qu'il ait une
concertation sérieuse c'est que nous ne
passions pas en force en même temps que
nous soyons un porteur de ce soir un sip
auquel nous tenons comme le fait de
préserver le système par répartition le
fait de lutter contre les inégalités
entre les hommes et les femmes
le fait de prendre en considération la
pénibilité du travail
tous les retraités ne sont pas face à la
même situation en fonction des métiers
ce sera quand même travailler plus
longtemps pour gagner moins avec des
pensions qui cesseront d'être indexée
sur l'inflation par exemple c'est ça la
réforme de gauche ce que ce sera si elle
est ce que ce sera c'est une réforme qui
tentera à la fois de répondre aux
objectifs que je viens de dire de
décliner et en même temps de se financer
car vous je vous rappelle que la réforme
de 2010 adoptée par le précédent
gouvernement prévoyait en gros
d'allonger donc la durée de cotisation
et puis l'âge légal pour rééquilibrer
les comptes
or on sait d'ores et déjà qu'on va aller
voir d'ici 2020 un déficit de 1 milliard
donc nous nous allons apporter des
réponses sérieuses aux petites questions
est ce que le chef de l'état ira rendre
visite aux parlementaires socialistes
après sa conférence de presse
oui ou non ça n'est pas exclu mais non
je lumière non non ça n'est pas exclu
mais je sais que c'est pas que je ne
connais pas que certains parlementaires
en effet ont décidé de se retrouver lui
est ce qu'il a décidé d'aller les voir
vous verrez c'est vraiment joli n'ya à
bon d'accord allez le climat engendrés
par le débat sur le mariage portance
va-t-il renvoyé à plus tard
même à boncourt plus tard les autres
réformes de société qui en vaut faveur
on le sait ma chatte vallaud-belkacem
question que nous posons avant
d'accueillir isabelle tornay de l'
agence france-presse
avec jérôme ravier avec le vote du texte
sur le mariage pour tous le gouvernement
tient sa grande réforme de société
son marqueur de gauche mais d'autres
réformes sociétales sont désormais
menacés loi sur la fin de vie
procréation médicalement assistée pour
les couples de femmes ou encore droit de
vote des étrangers
faute de majorité suffisante pour les
faire passer elles sont reportées voir
enterrée mais dans la majorité certains
pointent surtout la nécessité de passer
à autre chose
sa durée même j'allais dire ça a trop
duré
le texte sur mariage pour tous
maintenant il ya des textes qui nous
attendait sur l'importance pas de
contradiction pour moi mais clairement
la priorité celle économique et social
contre le chômage
mais pour certains parlementaires on
peut aussi trouver le temps d'étudier
ces sujets tout est question de volonté
politique dans le calendrier
parlementaire
il est toujours possible si on est
capable de de maîtriser les débats de
présenter des textes de loi celui sur la
fin de vie me paraît essentielle peut
toujours passer ces textes là ne
laissons pas de côté ne les oublions pas
la priorité c'est l'économie
mais au milieu il faut faire passer
aussi des textes qui concernent la
société ciel coincé entre une opposition
revigorée par des manifestations
imposantes et une aile gauche et ses
alliés qui tiennent au respect des
promesses données l'exécutif semble
avoir tranché
'nos entend maintenant le gouvernement
assez frileux sur des réformes de
société qui était prévu qu'ils sont
importantes
ce n'était pas une question seulement de
savoir si sans les sondages ça plaît ou
pas c'est que c'est le sens même d'un
gouvernement de gauche de pouvoir porter
ces transformations sociales et
sociétales
contraint par les déficits à ouvrir de
nouveaux chantiers comme la réforme des
retraites ou la refonte des allocations
familiales
le gouvernement ne peut ou ne veut
s'engager sur de nouvelles réformes de
société pas sûr que cela comble les
attentes des partisans de la majorité
revenir sur la loi sur le mariage pour
tous le conseil constitutionnel examine
actuellement les recours qui ont été
déposés par l'opposition où pourrait se
prononcer dès jeudi
est-ce que vous ne redoutez pas un
risque même infime
d'inconstitutionnalité
je n'ai aucun élément qui aujourd'hui me
permettent de vous répondre je redoute
où je ne redoute pas être précisément
c'est la liberté du conséquence ionel
que de se prononcer moi j'attends
sereinement la décision du conseil
constitutionnel
nous avons déjà passé un cap important
lorsque le parlement a voté le texte
parce que c'était un acte politique
qu'il fallait poser qui était un acte
fondateur qui était attendue depuis
franchement au moins une décennie
donc nous verrons bien ce que le
conséquence ionel décidera mais j'ai ouï
sérénité et puis at impatience pour être
tout à fait franche impatience de voir
les premiers mariages célébrés
parce que je pense vraiment que ça va
changer quelque chose dans le climat
général lorsque on va se rendre compte
que c'est d'abord de bonheur de plaisir
d'amour que l'on parle et qu'on va voir
finalement la diversité des familles que
cela concerne qui sont d'ores et déjà
concernés puisque le couple en fait ils
sont déjà en couple pour beaucoup
d'entre eux le fait d'avoir le droit de
se marier c'est un droit supplémentaire
mais ils existent déjà dont je pense que
ça va vraiment changer aussi la
perception du débat que de voir les
premiers mariages alors avant la
célébration de ses premiers mariages et
des nouvelles une nouvelle manifestation
nationale qui est prévue le 26 mai c'est
quoi selon vous c'est un simple baroud
d'honneur ou ont quelque chose de plus
profond
1 certains ont évoqué un mai 68 de
droite
moi j'ai dans l'absolu j'ai toujours du
mal à a dénoncé les manifestations parce
que j'ai pour avoir été longtemps dans
l'opposition je suis j'ai souvent battu
le pavé d'une certaine façon et donc il
faut respecter le droit fondamental à
manifester
en même temps il faut passer un message
clair aux manifestants qui est qu'à un
moment donné lorsque la loi devient
la règle lorsqu'elle est à adopter par
le parlement qui plus est lorsque le
conseil constitionnel la valider alors
il faut cesser de vouloir remettre en
cause la loi
c'est un principe républicain et donc
nous verrons nous en serons le 26 mai a
priori le conséquence ionel se sera
prononcé d'ici là bas également un vent
cette manifestation est ce que vous
redoutez un nouveau rassemblement
d'ampleur c'est difficile c'est de la
divination ce que vous demandez
objectivement junior numéro parce que
moi ce que je sais pour avoir vu à quoi
ressemblaient les manifestations donc
anti mariage pour tous jusqu'à présent
c'est qu'il y avait beaucoup de choses
en leur sein c'était très hétérogène et
qu'il ne faut pas non plus résumé les
manifestants anti mariage pour tous aux
casseurs aux des rappeurs parce que
c'est injuste aussi il y avait en effet
des familles qui simplement sortait pour
manifester une autre conception de la
société que je ne partage pas et je suis
toujours prête à discuter avec elle mais
qui ont droit aussi de manifester
pacifiquement donc moi je demande juste
à ce que les choses se fassent
pacifiquement et qu'à un moment donné on
respecte la règle tout cas l'opposition
entend s'en saisir pour appeler les
français à dire un non global à la
politique de françois hollande à ce que
le gouvernement c'est pas quand même
tiré une balle dans le pied avec avec
cette réforme donc l'opposition surtout
de choses pour moi j'étais en train de
commenter les manifestants pacifiques je
ne mettrai pas l'opposition exactement
dans le même passé donc nous serons là à
ce que l'opposition mais vous avez passé
l'opposition je lui reproche beaucoup
plus simplement et clairement d'avoir
exploité instrumentaliser ce sujet d'une
façon qui est même scandaleuse parce que
j'estime qu'elles mêmes comptable des
dérapages homophobes qui ont eu lieu
dans la mesure où elle a pu elle-même
tenir des propos au sein de l'hémicycle
qui sont absolument intolérable vous
assassiner des enfants et j'en passe et
c'est donc l'opposition moi j'estime
qu'elle n'a pas été responsable pour un
sou dans cette affaire maintenant est ce
qu on a bien fait de faire passer cette
réforme
du coup ça nous renvoie aux reportages
qu'on voyait tout à l'heure moi je vais
vous dire je quand je me suis engagé en
politique
je me suis pas engagé en politique pour
gérer des affaires pour simplement comme
un peu un fonctionnaire le ferais avoir
des dossiers à traiter des chantiers à
ouvrir à refaire mais je me suis engagé
en politique au nom de valeurs d'idéaux
d'un projet de société et il n'y a rien
de plus noble en politique que de
chercher à faire d'une certaine façon
grandir notre devise républicaine
liberté égalité fraternité c'est ça donc
les réformes de société et ses nobles je
romps fini par croire que c'est des
sujets périphériques qui viennent
brouiller l'essentiel mais pas du tout
ça fait partie de l'essentiel les
réformes de société et je vais vous dire
ça fait d'autant plus partie de l'
essentiel qu'on est en période de crise
pourquoi parce que c'est en période de
crise économique que la tentation du
repli sur soi du rejet de l'autre des
discriminations voire des violences et
le plus présente et donc c'est à ce
moment là que les pouvoirs publics
doivent dire égalité des droits
lutte contre l'homophobie lutte contre
les discriminations lutte contre les
violences justement la lutte contre
l'homophobie cch vous évoquez est ce que
c'est pas quand même un paradoxe de
cette loi finalement on a assisté
récemment à une recrudescence des
agressions il ya un rapport publié ce
matin qui portait certes sur 2012 mais
qui montre une hausse de 30% des actes
homophobes
est ce que cette loi n'a pas contribué à
relancer cette homophobie qui serait
paradoxal non
moi non sentiment à moi c'est que le
débat autour de la loi mariage pour tous
a mis en lumière la persistance au sein
de la société française d'un certain
nombre de réflexes homophobe mais qui
existait déjà
on en avait juste moins conscience parce
qu'on ne mettait pas les focales
médiatique dessus mais les actes de
violence homophobe et y en avait un
certain nombre on en déplorait
régulièrement y compris parfois qui
tourné au drame à la tragédie
aujourd'hui l'illusion d'une certaine
façon une plus grande tolérance mais
c'est intéressant parce que c'est les
illusions d'optique on en a souvent dans
le domaine qu'est le mien les droits des
femmes l'égalité homme femme je suis
souvent confrontés à ce phénomène où
finalement les gens pensent que moi tout
va bien que les grands combats sont
derrière nous quand on atteint légalité
que la société tolérante sur tous les
sujets mais c'est pas vrai d'abord tout
se fait toujours à plusieurs vitesses
donc qu'il ya des endroits où on est
plus tolérant qu'ailleurs il ya des
endroits où on n'est plus éclairée plus
ouverts qu'ailleurs et donc ce travail
finalement de conviction et de
réaffirmation de nos valeurs c'est un
travail constant pour le politique et
c'est un travail encore une fois qui est
noble qu'il faut pas abandonner en
disant ah mais si j'évoque ce sujet si
ça se trouve je vais provoqué des
réactions homophobes mais non pas du
tout au contraire il faut dire haut et
fort nous voulons l'égalité des droits
pour lutter contre notamment pas mal de
responsables socialistes qu'il faut
poursuivre donc appuyé même sur cette
réforme de société on en a besoin dans
une période troublée de crise économique
qui fait ressurgir de mauvais sentiments
n'est ce pas je vais vous dire encore
une dernière chose si vous permettez
c'est une erreur que d'opposer
l'économie sociale ou sociétale
parce que parfois la société ricoh oui
mais parfois le sociétal est un levier
de reprise de la croissance
je vais vous en donner un exemple en
prenez oui prenez l'égalité
hommes-femmes par exemple vous pourriez
me dire c'est un sujet périphériques
qu'est-ce que vous ne nous embêter avec
le sujet droits des femmes en ce moment
où on est en période de crise sauf que
travailler à l'égalité professionnelle
travailler au fait que les femmes soit
nacré autant d'entreprises que les
hommes
et bien c'est nous faire gagner
plusieurs points mais je sais de qui
montre effectivement que l'égalité
salariale hommes femmes est un facteur
de croissance
je voudrais qu'on vienne sur la misty
social que le gouvernement a dans un
premier temps défendu avant de s'y
opposer
les députés devraient décider jeudi de
renvoyer la proposition de loi en
commission est ce que c'est un moyen de
mieux l'enterrer
parce que l'on a l'impression que le ps
est complètement divisé sur cette
question qui veut plus faire aucune
concession au front de gauche
le parlement va faire son travail donc
les députés vont voir ce qu'ils font de
ce texte est de son renvoi en commission
des lois le gouvernement a dit les
choses très clairement vraiment le
gouvernement est opposé à l'adoption
d'une telle loi d'aministie société m'a
dit que c'était une oeuvre de justice
mais en fait ce qu'il faut bien
comprendre parce que je pense que c'est
pas toujours évident notamment pour les
téléspectateurs mais c'est que il ya
d'une part l'initiative gouvernementale
et puis à l'initiative parlementaire
donc parfois il est des propositions de
loi qu'ils viennent de députés qui
viennent de sénateurs qui ont été
travaillés au parlement et pas par le
gouvernement alors donc conçu un désaveu
pour les seuls sur lesquels on demande
c'était une proposition du front de
gauche mais peu importe sur lesquels on
se demande au gouvernement de se
prononcer lorsque ce texte admis ch'ti
social a été présenté au sénat
nous n'y étions pas favorable dans
l'absolu nous l'avions dit d'ailleurs
mais nous avons essayé d'améliorer le
texte pour faire en sorte qu'il soit
acceptable pour quoi nous nous y étions
pas favorables parce que c'est une
remise en cause de la chose jugée et que
remettre en cause la chose jugée
finissent finalement c'est porter
atteinte tout simplement à la règle qui
doit être la même pour tous dans le
temps si on estime que la règle n'est
pas bonne
alors on la change pour tous voilà donc
nous avions dit que nous n'étions pas
favorables à cette mesure nous avons
essayé de la retravailler de l'améliorer
nous ne sommes pas satisfaits de ce à
quoi nous avons abouti donc nous y
sommes opposés à une polémique en ce
moment sur l'enseignement en anglais
dans les facs françaises est la suivante
en pas du tout bizarrement la ministre
de la francophonie à minable
guy est ce que c'est ce genre ou par
peur d'un nouveau couac gouvernemental
pour être franc je ne comprends
absolument pas cette polémique moi je
veux bien qu'on ait un avis sur tout
mais enfin franchement que nos
universités puissent faire en sorte non
pas que l'ensemble de leurs
enseignements soient délivrés en langue
anglaise mais que certains leur
enseignement soit des livres en langue
anglaise permettant d'accueillir du coup
les universitaires des professeurs anglo
saxons et c'est de haut niveau et puis
des étudiants étrangers
je vous rappelle que tout ça participe
d'une logique générale dans laquelle
nous avons abrogé la circulaire guéant
pour faciliter la présence des étudiants
étrangers en france pour renforcer
l'attractivité de notre pays
vraiment je ne vois absolument pas ce
qu'il y à a reproché son bienfaiteur
parce qu'elle est contre et qui me dit
qu'elle est contre bâle et la
préposition manifestement elle a déjà
exprimé son opinion mais en tout cas moi
j'ai l'exemple
je vous dis alors d'abord comme porte
parole du gouvernement je vous dis cette
mesure est absolument soutenue
évidemment par le gouvernement et comme
et à titre personnel c'est évidemment un
levier de compétitivité sur les campus
américains issus des cours en anglais
il arrive que des cours soit des livres
en français figurez vous et oui mais
c'est ça qui est extraordinaire je ne
comprends même pas où est le sujet
vraiment cool vérifier en donne rarement
des cours en langue étrangère à
l'étranger ou bien sur pc mais signe
parce qu'il y à des cours de littérature
française dans certaines universités
américaines je pensais qu'il n'y a pas
de sujet en revanche la francophonie la
défense de la francophonie est un beau
sujet dans l'absolu en fait il faut pas
se tromper de combat
la défense de la francophonie ça se fait
par d'autres moyens ça se fait en
faisant en sorte que la france continue
à avoir un potentiel d'influencé dans un
certain nombre de pays où le français
concurrencé par d'autres langues enfin
sur notre propre territoire
a priori notre langue n'est pas
concurrencer
un sujet encore très polémique mais
allocations familiales
un sujet qui divise les français jean
marc ayrault va faire des annonces très
prochainement alors déjà avez vous une
date qu'on sache enfin ce qui va se
passer avec les allocations familiales
est est ce que c'est c'est pas quand
même une réforme à haut risque alors bon
je vais fermer non vous en saurez plus
si d'ici la fin de la semaine sur la
date précise des annonces quant au fond
de la faire c'est je pense que les
français comprennent très bien qu'un
système qui a été adoptée au lendemain
de la seconde guerre mondiale notre
système de commentaires d'allocations
familiales protection sociale puisse
avoir besoin d'être modernisée pourquoi
je vous dis ça regardez de sujets
auxquels je suis particulièrement
attentive évidemment comme liste des
droits des femmes
aujourd'hui on a besoin de multiplier
les places de crèche
tout le monde compte où les parents le
comprennent très bien on n'en a pas
assez dans notre pays si on veut
multiplier les places de crèche il faut
trouver des recettes pour les financer
donc réformer d'une certaine façon la
politique familiale dans ce sens
deuxième sujet aujourd'hui contrairement
à il ya 50 ans vous avez eu un
développement des familles
monoparentales exponentielle avec
notamment des situations de mères
isolées dans une grande difficulté une
grande précarité auxquels nous devons
faire face nous devons apporter des
réponses
donc nous allons apporter des réponses
par exemple en faisant en sorte que les
pensions alimentaires qui ne sont pas
versées puissent être compensées par un
autre système garantit contre ces
impayés de pension alimentaire
tout cela réclame des moyens donc du
coup vous comprenez très bien pourquoi
nous avons besoin de réformes et de
moderniser notre politique familiale
merci j'avais le tourner alors perrine
tarneaud de police et pourtant c'était
d'abord des éléments de portrait sur
vous avec un mixeur et colinot
najat vallaud belkacem aurait pu faire
tout autre chose que de la politique
avocate aux journalistes par exemple son
nom à d'ailleurs été évoquée pour la
présentation d'un journal télévisé sont
arrivés parmi les éléphants du ps il ya
dix ans tiens au hasard d'une rencontre
avec caroline colomb la femme du maire
de lyon qui lui propose d'intégrer le
cabinet de son mari et elle va lui dire
oui mais même en pensée au départ qu'il
s'agit d'un cabinet d'avocats on sait
que après qu'elle va découvrir que c'est
le maire de lyon que c'est de la
politique marocaine arrivée en france à
4 ans naturalisé à 18 ans puis diplômé
de sciences politiques
la bonne élève apprend auprès de gérard
collomb le terrain et le tractage elle
qui n'a aucune années de militantisme
inscrire sur son cv
mais c'était moins des premiers pas a
pris ses distances
oui c'est un animal politique en
particulier c'est un animal médiatique
la gêne les codes de la politique et de
la communication c'est auprès de
ségolène royal qu'elle les acquiert
comme porte parole durant la campagne de
2007 pour son ami le député gwendal
rouillard
c'est un tournant dans sa carrière elle
a été beaucoup marqué par la manière
dont ségolène royal a été traitée
pendant la campagne présidentielle de
elle en a tiré les enseignements se
protéger personnellement et garder cette
distance utile et indispensable par
rapport aux fonctions qui sont les
siennes des codes qu'elle applique aussi
à ses mentors
c'est une de ses forces c'est ce qui
fait qu'elle est monté et elle sait
qu'elle m'ait jamais
deux rapports affectifs avec ces gens là
elle fait que ça peut être dangereux
donc du coup les rapports sont assez
sains aujourd'hui à 36 ans porte parole
du gouvernement et ministre
elle n'exclut pas un jour de faire tout
autre chose que de la politique
créer sa propre entreprise par exemple
pourrait bien l'attenté du gouvernement
sur comme ceux des journalistes
bonsoir l'animal médiatique dit gérard
collomb il a pris l'espèce de distance
par rapport à vous il vous en veut
d'être parti si loin de lui
non je crois pas je ne veux pas me
bercer d'illusions mais je ne vois rien
de désobligeant dans son propos qu'est
ce qui veut dire je pense c'est que ça
que ma fonction de porte parole
aujourd'hui de gouvernement en 2012 de
porte parole de françois hollande
pendant la campagne présidentielle en
2007 de porte parole de ségolène royal
pendant la présidentielle fait que par
définition je suis plutôt présente dans
les médias mais c'est normal je fais mon
travail en quelques salaires vous en
vouloir de prix j'ai surtout le côté
médiatique peut-être pas le fond à ce
moment là je ne sais pas si c'est ce
qu'il ressent en tout cas si c'est ce
qu'il ressent alors ils se trompent
parce que je crois que moi ce qui me
maintient en politique parce que vous
savez la politique il ya des eaux il ya
débat il ya des moments où vous
décourager ou vous demander si c'est
vraiment votre place des kora est des
moments où vous enthousiasmer et ce qui
me maintient en politique c'est un
engagement viscéral pour un projet de
société vraiment un idéal que j'arrive
très bien à visualiser
et ce depuis des années maintenant c'est
à dire plus de justice plus d'égalité
faire en sorte que les gens et l'égalité
d'opportunités finalement quel que soit
leur milieu d'origine leur parcours
voilà c'est ça qui m'intéresse et donc
je sais ce que je fais là je ne suis pas
là par hasard
donc le fond je crois que c'est ça les
gérard collomb justement que vous avez
mis donc le pied à l'étrier en politique
il est aujourd'hui sur une ligne très
social libéral comment vous vous situez
lui par rapport à sa position politique
pour moi c'est j'ai appris la politique
en partie aux côtés de gérard collomb
quand même moi je lui suis redevable de
beaucoup de choses c'est pour ça que je
ne veux rien voir de désobligeant qui
ces propos mais c'est vrai que je me
souviens il ya une dizaine d'années
quand je suis arrivé à lyon à ses côtés
que je les ai vus vrai franchement c'est
un très bon maire a lyon c'est il a été
excellent il est ex élu récemment entre
le gouvernement ce que je veux dire
c'est que il faut déjà lui reconnaître
cette capacité à défendre un socialisme
qui est un socialisme j'allais dire de
l'offre c'est-à-dire d'abord produire
créer les conditions de la production
avant de penser à la redistribution je
crois que c'est ce qui le définit sans
doute le mieux et c'est vrai que
l'agglomération lyonnaise est
aujourd'hui la plus entreprenante de
france c'est vrai qu'il a initiés
beaucoup de choses créer des emplois
dans sa ville etc etc on peut
lui reconnaître dont ceux ci parfois
ligne dure notamment sur la sécurité on
l'a vu encore avec l' affaire des roms
cette semaine l'accident mortel d'hier
on lui reproche des expulsions l'
incendie mortel des expulsions
systématiques des familles roms à ce que
vous soutenez cette ligne là aussi c'est
d'avancer ces deux sujets différents
juste pour finir sur l'économie et le
social
moi je crois vraiment que sa politique
ce qu'il appelle le modèle lyonnais a
fait ses preuves et que de ce point de
vue là on est paumé libéral un modèle
réformiste je le qualifierais comme ça
donc de ce point de vue là lorsqu'il
fait des suggestions gouvernement
lorsqu'il fait des propositions moi je
les prends plutôt positivement c'est à
dire que il est là pour défendre une
ligne dont on a besoin au sein du parti
socialiste y en a d'autres mais lui il
est le gardien d'une certaine façon de
dutemple réformiste voilà sur maintenant
pour la caution de la sécurité c'est je
suis lyonnaise moi même donc je vois
très bien de quel squat
il s'agissait et permettez-moi d'abord
de dire vraiment ma profonde tristesse à
l'égard de ce qui s'est passé hier c'est
une tragédie absolue que la mort de ces
trois personnes est ce qu'il faut dire
sur ce sujet c'est qu'en réalité cet
incendie horrible vient conforter la
politique qui est celle du gouvernement
c'est à dire la nécessité de reloger de
mettre fin à des squats qui ne garantit
aucune condition de sécurité par gérard
collomb qui lui fait l'expulsion
attendez avant de reloger ont bien sûr
on demande aux gens de partir c'est ce
qui était prévu et c'est ce qui est
terrible c'est que c'est ce qui était
prévu sur ce squat il était prévu que
l'expulsion est lieu je crois mercredi
ce mercredi sachant qu'ils sont
installés là 200 personnes depuis
octobre donc ça traînait depuis deux
mois oui oui mais parce que ça pourrait
se prolonger mais le problème est
difficile est vraiment j'aimerais bien
qu'on ne fasse pas de polémique autour
de cette affaire parce que je trouve
qu'il y aurait quelque chose de très
gênant à à utiliser d'une certaine façon
ce drame mais ce qui est vrai c'est que
qui sont parfois insolubles aspirations
des français sur le sujet bien sûr ouais
des riverains jour on comprend tout cela
et en même temps il ya une solution à
gérer avec humanité donc il faut à la
fois appliquer les décisions de justice
donc nous fermer les squats lorsque l'on
considère qu'ils ne sont pas
suffisamment sécurisé etc et en même
temps trouver des solutions de
relogement et puis travailler avec les
pays d'origine et lyon pour revenir à
gérard collomb lyon a été très innovante
dans le travail notamment avec la
roumanie vous savez qu'un partenariat a
été développé avec une ville en roumanie
dans laquelle nous créons sur place des
infrastructures d'accueil des robes
aider les populations à revenir vivre
chez elle il s'agit pas de dire que ce
sera la solution idéale pour l'ensemble
des populations roms mais enfin je crois
qu'il faut utiliser tous les leviers
d'action pour résoudre cette question
très difficile pour revenir sur votre
combat féministe on va dire où vous
puisez les racines de ce combat dans le
combat pour l'égalité de manière plus
générale or il se trouve que l'égalité
hommes femmes a souvent nourris tous les
autres combats contre les
discriminations pour l'égalité des
droits quelle que soit l'orientation
sexuelle quelle que soit l'origine et
c'est ce qu'on a conquis par exemple
dans les années soixante dix avec les
combats féministes a ensuite irriguer
toute la société est permis d'obtenir
des avancées sur les sujets comme la
diversité sur à sion après les droits
civiques après orange et la
contraception maintenant on va vers quoi
vous voulez tendre vers l'égalité totale
légalité
c'est quoi exactement l'égalité c'est
pas l'indifférenciation l'égalité des
opportunités l'égalité des droits
c'est dire au fond on comment dire le
panel de possibilités qui s'offrent à
vous ne doit pas être conditionnée par
l'endroit où vous êtes né le sexe qui
est le vôtre la famille à laquelle vous
appartenez
quel que soit le lieu où vous êtes né le
sexe ou la famille ou l'orientation
sexuelle qui est la vôtre vous deux
et avoir un panel d'opportunités qui
soit égal à celui de votre voisin qui a
des caractéristiques différentes et bien
appliqué cette définition là ce qui vous
entoure vous allez voir que ça n'est pas
le cas aujourd'hui que les situations
d'inégalité sont très très fréquentes
liées à l'origine liées au sexe et
s'agissant du sexe les gens croient
souvent que aujourd'hui qu'on soit homme
ou qu'on soit femme on a les mêmes
opportunités dans la vie moi je vous dis
que non quand vous pensez que la moitié
des femmes actives aujourd'hui sont
concentrés dans seulement 12 métier 12
familles de métiers sur une palette de
90 vous voyez moi j'ai un problème loi
cadre sur l'égalité au mois de septembre
devant le parlement on est en train d'y
travailler très activement et ce sera
une loi qui aura vocation finalement à
traiter tous azimuts les inégalités
partout où elles sont mais en changeant
de rythme en allant plus vite
c'est-à-dire en travaillant à la fois
sur l'immédiat lutter contre les
violences faites aux femmes traitées les
auteurs de ces violences
assurer l'égalité professionnelle
réellement dans l'entreprise faire la
parité pas seulement au parlement mais
aussi dans toutes les instances les
fédérations sportives les chambres de
commerce et d'industrie etc
et puis traiter les choses sur le long
terme c'est à dire apprendre l'égalité
aux enfants dès le plus jeune âge j'ai
compris comme une éducation non sexiste
dès la rentrée prochaine ça veut dire
important mais c'est un apprentissage à
l'égalité filiation c'est-à-dire type de
genre lutter contre les stéréotypes en
effet ça signifie j'ai assisté
d'ailleurs des expériences qui sont
menées comme ça auprès d'enfants de 6 7
ans ça signifie ouvrir les yeux des
petites filles et des petits garçons sur
le fait que être pompier c'est pas
forcément simplement réservé aux garçons
que on peut
vous voyez être une fille est malgré
tout avoir des appétences ou des envies
ou des rêves et là je sais déjà à
l'école très masculine être une fille et
pratiquer du sport parce que par
définition pratiquer du sport c'est
utile pour développer les fonctions
motrices être un garçon est pratiquée de
la musique parce que là encore sybase
oui mais de fait tout le monde est
d'accord mais des faux passeports
la nôtre est pardon mais de fait on ne
traite absolument pas les garçons et les
filles de la même façon et on ne
développe pas les mêmes capacités les
mêmes compétences chez les uns les
autres ce qui se retrouve quelques
années plus tard dans la vie active
toute dernière question vous avez
répondu un peu par anticipation tout à
l'heure sur l'enseignement en anglais
dans les facs françaises est bien plus
de 40 députés ps ont décidé de monter au
créneau contre ce texte de la ministre
de l'enseignement supérieur
ils dénoncent le risque de
marginalisation des étudiants
francophones et ils font fausse route iv
c est du socialiste à l'assemblée
écoutez moi je ne partage pas je ne
partage pas leur angoisse je ne sais pas
d'ailleurs sur quoi elles reposent moi
je sors j'estime qu'aujourd'hui notre
pays doit se projeter se projeter à la
faute dans l'avenir se projeter dans le
monde a tiré
être compétitif donc que d'une certaine
façon se replier sur soi même avoir peur
des autres c'est totalement antinomique
avec cette projection dans l'avenir et
dans le monde
voilà pour compléter votre réponse de
tout à l'heure sur le sujet merci
perrine merci najat merci à la nouvelle
scène merci d'avoir été avec nous cette
semaine et la semaine prochaine c'est
votre collègue benoît hamon qui sera à
votre place
bonsoir à tous et à très vite
une semaine politique et parlementaire
passé au crible de l'image et du
questionnement la compétitivité
maintenant c'est un problème le coût du
travail qui n'était pas un problème qui
n'existait pas nous maintenant un
problème
la crise écologique et plus en plus
vivre eh bien on a besoin de changer les
choses et rapidement parlement hebdo
pour ne rien manquer pour tout
comprendre
c'est vendredi à 17h45
il est un peu plus de 12 heures 30 le
candidat socialiste arrive sur place
telle une star de rugby dans une mêlée
non sans difficultés il réussit à se
rendre avec les représentants de
l'intersyndicale sur une scène
improvisée
le message est clair il n'est pas
question pour lui de laisser tomber les
salariés de florange et d'ail anges
il faut qu'une loi soit très rapidement
adopté pour traiter ces situations
quand une grande firme ne veut plus d'un
une unité de production ne veut pas non
plus la cd nous en saurions obligations
pour que des repreneurs vienne et
puissent donner une activité
supplémentaire solution suppose d'abord
de faire pression sur me tall pour que
il ré ouvre le plus vite possible et aux
fourneaux des solutions c'est si mittal
ne veut pas garder cette activité qu il
la cède à ce moment là un repreneur qui
puisse la faire vivre des solutions
celle qu ce projet de grande
modernisation qui va permettre de faire
travailler ce site
la solution c'est d'avoir confiance dans
l'industrie sidérurgique et de la
soutenir dans la durée et pas simplement
lorsque il y a une difficulté
voilà la solution nas avis sur la
solution le problème c'est que toutes
ces solutions égrainé par le candidat
n'ont pas été mis en oeuvre un ce qui a
amené on s'en souvient en décembre à
l'annoncé de la fermeture définitive des
hauts fourneaux du coup les ouvriers lui
reproche ses promesses de campagne alors
question ses promesses et l imprudente
et at il eu tort de tenir ces propos
avec le recul guy alvez on est dans le
cas classique des discours de campagne
électorale qui dans la durée va se
confronter au discours de réalité du
quotidien
la question est ce que françois hollande
ne pouvait tenir un autre discours à ce
moment là hélas pas je pense pas parce
qu'il enterrait sa campagne sur s'il
était la fois
à florange où à petroplus pour dire je
pourrais le faire pour vous on se
souvient de 2007 et est de 2,7 par an
dès 2011 pas donc on est en face d'un
vrai sujet pour les hommes politiques
qui soient le disque de franchise soit
un discours de l'instant et c'est vrai
que pendant la campagne électorale
l'efficacité l'obligation de résultat
prime sur certaines obligations
d'honnêteté intellectuelle et de de
pédagogie le temps ne laisse pas la
pédagogie
donc ils sont obligés de faire au plus
vite et au plus efficace à l'instant
mais le temps se rappelle de très
rapidement voilà qui est elle payée au
prix fort hills après ce n'est enfin
entre les promesses volontariste du
début et puis finalement les réalités ce
que ce que c'est ça c'est le piège de
florange pour françois hollande c'est
que paradoxalement quand il se rend à
florange il essaye de ne pas trop
promettre et il dit sur la camionnette
je ne ferai pas comme un certain
président qui est venu à gandrange extra
il veut marquer le contraste et c'est
quand les journalistes l'interrogent
quand ils descendent la camionnette et
que les journalistes le pouce qu'il est
obligé d'en dire un peu plus cette
acquisition la solution la solution
voilà c'est ça et par ailleurs mais
qu'il ait dit ça ou pas aux journalistes
de toute manière l'image en tant que
telle image du candidat devenu chef
d'état sur la camionnette vos promesses
et c'est tout le piège de ce dossier
pour françois hollande c'est que ici
engagé personnellement et physiquement
et que maintenant ne peut que décevoir
à la radio on a trouvé intéressant de
revenir sur un sujet qu'il a beaucoup
évoqué celui de sa timidité
on commence par la mer ont ils en parler
avant d'être à matignon en mai 2006 on
écoute faut pas sous-estimer que c'est
c'est souvent une épreuve à chaque fois
pour franchir un cap
l'épreuve se sont eux mêmes
parce que cette timidité naturelle mais
oblige à faire un effort supplémentaire
que d'autres ne font pas parce que c'est
plus spontané ils n'ont pas de complexe
d'être de se mettre en scène d'aller
vers les autres voient la timidité
naturelle dit-il en 2006 on les écoute
maintenant en mai 2012 lors de sa
nomination à matignon on a compensé les
motions ben vous savez je ne vais pas
cacher cette émotion même si j'étais
quelqu'un de pudique et réservé mais
même un peu timide et même un peu timide
en mai 2012
on écoute maintenant quelques mois plus
tard lorsqu'il est bien installée à
matignon est-ce que c'est pas un
cauchemar d'être à matignon quand on est
timide
non je n'ai je vais vous dire je n'ai
éprouvé aucune inquiétude lorsque je
suis arrivée à matignon
j'avais l'impression d'avoir déjà été la
cible et c'est presque une confidence
que je vous fais là on m'a pas du tout
impressionné
j'ai l'expérience de toutes façons de du
pouvoir j'ai l'expérience de l'état je
connais tout en restant timide non
réservés c'est pas la même chose
la réserve vise à éradiquer le sens non
mais une certaine forme de timidité
telle qu'elle est perçue à la évidemment
la question qu'on se pose c'est timide
ou pas on va vous faire réagir je m'en
fous qu'il connaissait depuis longtemps
mais peut-être un petit mois sophie
cadalen sur la manière d'en parler et
sur l'évolution de cette manière de
parler cette chose très personnelle
qu'est la timidité qui est pas toujours
facile quand on est un homme politique
de premier plan
oui alors moi je trouve ça tout à fait
cohérent cette espèce dégoût de ce
passage mais moins en moins timide de
timidité à réserve
c'est quelque chose qui est pas rare
chez les humains et a notamment qui peut
se s'entendront travail d' analyse mais
c'est quelque part le dépassement de de
cette timidité qui a été posée comme non
c'est pas pour moi et si si c'est pour
moi et d'ailleurs il le dit je trouve ça
très puissant quand il dit je suis
arrivée à matignon
je connaissais c'était chez moi il le
dit à sa manière
voilà il ya quelque chose qui